chaque été des milliers d'animaux sont
abandonnés sur les routes et livrés à
eux mêmes pourtant cette année la
société protectrice des animaux a dû
faire face à une arrivée encore plus
massive de chatons en cause la
possibilité de stériliser les félins
pendant le confinement
face à cette situation la spa a lancé
une campagne d'adoption pour venir en
aide à ces s'attachant de boules de
poils aujourd'hui nous avons une
vingtaine de chatons à l'adoption donc
on en a à présent au refuge qui viennent
directement de fourrière et donc qui ont
été trouvées comme ça sur des communes
malheureusement soit de propriétaires
qui n'ont pas fait le nécessaire au
niveau de la stérilisation de leurs
chats ou des chats sauvages qui
malheureusement se reproduisent entre
eux et augmentent la population féline
chaque chaton est soigneusement prise en
charge soit directement au refuge soit
dans une famille relais en attendant son
sevrage second prêt pour nous proposons
à l'adoption ce sont des chatons qui ont
plus de deux mois ils sont sevrés ils
ont au moins un premier vaccin
la responsable de la spa plaisir
rappelle que l'adoption d'un animal quel
qu'il soit demande du temps et de
l'attention
une mauvaise gestion de la besoin peut
même entraîner des troubles du
comportement pour les animaux ayant mal
vécu leur abandon une situation dont
inconscience ce futurs adoptants
on n'est pas venu chercher vraiment un
chaton mais c'est donner une deuxième
chance à un animal quoi qui est
peut-être avait que quelque chose
deux malheureux donc là on voulait
donner une deuxième chance simplement
depuis le confinement
la spa a déjà accueilli 8000 700 animaux
abandonnés
un chiffre qui risque d'augmenter
puisque la période de reproduction des
chats se poursuit jusqu'à fin septembre